yousfi d'aujourd'hui se trouvaient trois
mois sur quoi inquiéter mais cette fois
en solo en entamant j'adore ce jeu je
passe tout mon temps dessus donc on va
jouer en classe et au moins leur petit
cassoulet pendant que st pierre a jugé
aujourd'hui vous allez voir comme j'ai
progressé sur ce jeu c'est spectaculaire
au départ on y voit un débat on frappe
la balle ramstad d'asie mettaient de la
chute massive à zuera même style
beaucoup m'ont dit ton [ __ ] une pseudo
je blogue cette balle elle est pour moi
et personne d'autre
ok allez c'est bien on y va on y va on y
va et hop la butte
je lui ai dit que j'étais devenu un
joueur pro de faim projet avec qui ne
sont plus un joueur qui sait faire un
tir quand il a la balle
seul devant les cages et gauguin
défenseur ait pas de gaulle joue baisse
technique secret du l'apport âge est un
[ __ ] nord olala la chance allait il a
mais pas [ __ ] la mer
et ça c'est pour moi ça oh là là j'avais
anticipé
regardez là jamais regardé les cons
l'écho et le lob
alors là alors là je fais la gueule
alors la suisse est bon vas-y francky
c'est bon le wallon aux plages là mais à
habsheim et ben voila voila c'était
chorégraphié c'était camel ou rêver non
mais là là là je peux jouer angers du
cassoulet à mumbai state magie rammstein
non non non il n'a pas misé 10 mais non
mais aller gagner en bleu et là vous
vous dites que c'est grâce à michel pas
ce que voulait me rabaisser et vous
savez ray seront parents à berne au sco
je veux me rendre mon ce qu'ils en ont
ça rentre
oh là là voilà avait là on n'a pas le
temps sur ma les steaks et là vous dites
c'est de la chance bah oui et vous avez
le réseau bordel nom même est amer plus
tard la chose si là le mec il est mort à
les sauvetages question à faire beau lot
ce que tu vas faire ça dans ses cages
non non non c'est moi le boss et là il
en paie les îles en train de pleurer
notre king when you fucking wade n'ont
pas qing wang nan ça qingwei
s'intéressant oui alors il est trop naze
oui merci c'est intéressant oui merci
merci toc c'est la wii toc génère des
pertes on sait pas quoi faire
allez allez à plus toxiques et onenote
rd il va il va essayer de la mettre et
il va la mettre
c'est trop ce que je voulais dire c'est
la bac la balle elle va j'adore j'adore
le voir ramper ont sauvé ce but il a
quitté le match au [ __ ] produit car il
a pu le faire suer pour fait si la
saucisse au fait ça avec la saucisse du
cassoulet ok on est content d'azap
fût-elle de ça c'est mauvais c'est son
pseudo veut rien dire des gens [ __ ] il
alors et rush aime pas ce qu'on leur
école je ne veux pas qu'on me tue pas
les bons il s'est passé quoi avec
je crois que j'ai eu de la chance il ya
dix ans mon dieu je joue là à ces du
skin merci bros rôle qu aller de l'appel
on croit en toi c'est raté allez allez
allez allez allez adorer ça nous avait
tous chantés du la fouine ce qui se
passe mais qui peuvent stopper rêver
monte à rien des lois elle a son petit
goal là haut j'ai jonglé avec la balle
on aurait dit zizou
on aurait dit zizou bande haut il a
quitté loi mais [ __ ] vont faire
inscrire tout le monde mais dit comme je
vais open vient de loin j'viens dagar
you hell bourg
là ils ont dû mettre contre à port lay
vu j'ai gagné mon lit contre a fort bien
joué bien jouer voilà tu es une petite
bière jouer sa technique des gens qui
n'ont jamais fait l'amour
non mais c'est vrai regardez j'ai jamais
fait l'amour un bonjour je viens leur
recul et je vais leur culek du vinaigre
mon gars oh c'est gentil ça
non moi je rate ça mais je suis plus
grande est qu au voilà voilà dehors doit
s'arroger lui dire désolé ça le
perturber ou alors le karma d'affaires
que je me prends des buts le quart balle
à terre non non non non non non non non
non mais de dacca attention
l'aléa plus dans le but
bla non mais mais mais c'est une blague
ok au revoir
mais maintenant tu laisses ça marche
plus ça marche plus ça marche bleue mais
[ __ ] de merde pourquoi ça a buggé
c'est à bugger on vient de revenir au
menu comme ça oh la la seconde à
bagnolet que c'est jackie chan quoi
pourra trouver le sac qui chef du rocket
ligue dans allez tu vas dans les cages
et la balade est ok joffard autour
windows de temps de gérer un petit un
petit problème de capture et l'eau a
profité pour marquer un but de vous
savez quoi on s'avoue pas vaincue on va
défoncer voilà voilà ça c'est parce
qu'il était de mauvaise foi il avait
jeté avec elle en a profité à boom du
coup moi j'arrive et je fais ça et toi
tu fais quoi
je sais pas mais tu l'as contre pas à
ses intérêts sans web alors excusez moi
pardon monsieur médias but mais sinon je
t'aime beaucoup l'insolence la
définition de l'insolence walla je
t'offre un but tu t'enflammes non mais
j'aime bien le fair play
attention jamais ta vie tes cordes et à
regarder les galères et voilà bonjour
jean michel galère je sais pas quoi
faire à part besoin d'un but mais un
seul ans est l'une des plus longues à
l'air un peu jackson
le mec un jeu projet tfk le karma s'est
acharné sur lui et c'est là bas j'ai un
peu malade surtout les contre moi bon
ben voilà est-ce qu'on a vaincu
oui on oublie match d'avant je bête nous
essayer au tout le monde du seuil haut
du 13 mike faut se méfier
ok le mec c'est une fusée c'est plus et
a refusé de mettre ses torpilles cents
d'économies
jean michel fau filage hop là on y va on
y va on y va on y va on y va on l'a la
vitesse comment j'ai mis ce but comme
angélisme fait exprès au nom n'est que
je vais toucher l'arrière trop [ __ ]
[Musique]
brigitte roth qui était arrive mais qui
peuvent que l'on fait je viens de loire
et vu mon temps je fais bien
non ça c'est dur mais ça c'est dur avec
ça si tu j'ai des nouilles dans le cul à
autrement dit j'ai le cul bordé de
nouilles aux plats à cette anticipation
de mouvement aux îles et faire payer du
13 on la prie points
quelqu'un de corrompus et voilà alors la
grèce et plus des nouilles qui a dans le
cul mec c'est ses spaghettis quoi alors
sa seconde marque un petit dernier a
laissé pourrions du 13
attention lieu du 13 c'est squeeze
aujourd'hui aux troupes pour mettre un
bon but à quelqu'un par exemple à cet
homme qui fuit la finir on pénètre dans
3 2 1
c'est la pls on a encore le temps de
marquer lé seul emerson et ma vie
personnelle ou presque aujourd'hui je
passe au dessus aux baisses fin de match
ever
je viens de loin et je ne viens pas
d'une sur quatre que j'avais envie d'en
faire une passion là je me suis amélioré
j'avais envie de claquer des fesses
voilà et à devenir à te faire [ __ ] un
mec m'a battu ici mais ça vous regarde
et n'hésitez pas à mes lèvres 2 ap los
tres cassoulet merci je tenterai matin
d'une prochaine portez vous bien au
chaud tout le monde
action beat ce type était pas mal